our responsibility is to always inspire
Sunday marked the Bryant family's first
Father's Day without Kobe Bryant but his
family found a little joy with the help
of a new family member a teeny tiny itty
bitty puppy
Vanessa shared this snap on Instagram
over the weekend
that's her 17 year old daughter Natalia
smiling from ear-to-ear cradling her
brand-new four-legged friend the mom of
three captioned the pic in part quote
love seeing my girls smile meet Bobby
the 38 year old revealed that bobby was
named after Iceman from x-men because he
has blue eyes
but before they settled on the name
Vanessa had been trying to decide
between Bobby and Bodhi and she even
asked fans to weigh in
posting a poll on her instace story cute
right well buckle up because it gets
even cuter Phoebe what did you say no
what did you just say right now I'm glad
that way
yeah apparently three-year-old Bianca
missed the memo that the dog actually
belongs to her big sister Vanessa
captioned the adorable clip quote so I
got Natalia a new dog and then this
happened a day earlier the family
celebrated another milestone capris
first birthday in one post Vanessa
shared how their little girl Capri Cobie
was named after her dearly missed daddy
the family also posed together for this
bday pic and Vanessa posted this shot of
Capri in her birthday dress sitting in
front of a ton of balloons and a giant
cake inspired by the Tokyo Disney Castle
on Sunday Vanessa shared a sweet
Father's Day tribute to Kobe who died
alongside the couple's 13 year old
daughter Gianna in a helicopter crash in
January she posted this throwback pic
with a basketball legend and their
daughters writing we miss you so much we
love you forever and always Kobe's Widow
also shared this snap in her insta story
writing my girls put a smile on my face
every day we Brian spent 20 years with
the Lakers dedicated to becoming the
best player in the world but what he
enjoyed the most was being a husband to
Vanessa and a father to Natalia Gianna
Bianca and debris and during Sunday
night's twenty20 ESPY Awards Kobe's
former Los Angeles Lakers teammate Pau
Gasol paid tribute to the late athlete
we all remember you smiling happiness so
vividly whenever he spoke about his
family he may be known as one of the
greatest athletes of all time but he was
also one of the best girl debts of all
time though we lost Kobe and his
beautiful daughter GG five months ago
today his legacy is alive on the streets
of LA a city that he loves so much proof
lies in the assortment of murals that
cover the city far and wide a tribute to
his impact now and forever Snoop Dogg
recorded a special tribute to Kobe as a
video showcase some of the many murals
that popped up all over the city
la honoring the basketball legend your
weather to the rain in your heart in
your brain trying to learn it to rain
ice water in your veins
[Music]